here's what would happen if Jupiter
became a star
Jupiter's big but it doesn't have enough
Mass to initiate a fusion reaction in
its core that's the necessary
requirement to become accepted into the
star Club however 80 Jupiters crushed
together would make a red dwarf out of
the gas giant but like every red dwarf
out there it wouldn't be too bright
Earth wouldn't be getting much heat from
it either since it's four times further
away from us than the Sun but we could
still see it a new star in our solar
system would slightly shift the orbits
of the other planets but not enough to
send them on a collision course with one
another or to launch them out of their
orbits into outer space the only threat
we'd face would be space rocks from the
asteroid belt that Jupiter might push
toward Earth we'd need to detect and
Destroy them before they could reach us
but other than that not much would
change for the solar system because